it's a time we call them out all the
interviewers out there who've shown a
total lack of manners and kindness
especially with young actors aside from
Millie Bobby Brown who had some weather
issues during an interview the rest of
these young actors got stuck with rude
invasive and totally inappropriate
questions and they didn't hold back with
the sarcastic quotes either anyway
Millie the wind did her dirty at this
Premiere she walked out wearing this
gorgeous pink number you Pink Dream I
can't handle it the problem this
interviewer just kept on going despite
the fact that Millie was clearly
struggling poor Millie she couldn't even
focus on her answers episode oh God
episode and then the interviewer just
casually pronounces her character's name
wrong so and maleven seems like more of
a thing this season can you tell us
anything about that which Millie just
rolled with I'm 11 is my favorite you
can just feel the cringe between them
and maleven seriously that's not even a
real name there's no blaming the wind on
this one though this interviewer was
just plain bad Howard Stern grilled
Harry Styles over some personal family
business like his parents divorce was he
one of those guys that like had nothing
to do with the family once he moved away
dude not the time he was obviously
trying to get Harry to spill some dirt
on his childhood and when Harry wouldn't
he switched to talking about Harry's
stepfather and then you had a stepfather
yes and you like that guy yes you can
just see the awkwardness in Harry's eyes
and it isn't even over yet and Hebrews
he did if you knew about it then why
bring it up just bad timing dude and now
we crushed some stereotypes with Ariana
Grande no judging the guys from Power
106 FM but like a question like this is
this seriously how they want to spend
their time with an icon like Ariana
Grande if you could
you could or your phone one last time
which one would you pick Ari's response
is this what you think girls have
trouble choosing yeah yeah you'd think
you would have taken the hint but no he
demands to know if Ari's even capable of
going anywhere without her phone yes how
long can you go without looking at it
many hours Ariana took this chance to
teach the boys a lesson I have a long
list of things I'd like to change
meanness and
um double standards misogyny Ari we are
with you all the way now this crew of
people full adult humans they took rude
to a whole new level on live television
with Karen De Levine okay first off they
get our name wrong Carla Delevingne is
in the movie she joins us live from New
York City
strike one then they hop right onto the
rude train with this garbage question do
you even have time to sit and read these
days you're so busy
ouch you're not the right tone Cara
tried to play it off with a joke uh no I
never read the book or the script
actually I kind of winged it but they
just didn't get it why don't you go take
a little nap maybe get a Red Bull how
about that we can't blame Cara for
cutting her video call there the awkward
questions really never stop even with
the newer generation of actors like
Rowan Blanchard who believe it or not
was actually asked if she had any
dieting tips for teenage girls Rowan
just responded saying I mean come on I
don't diet I'm 13. and if she did have
any dieting tips she says if you don't
order fries you'll probably be mad and
yeah we got to agree with that one so
we're wondering why there was some weird
trend of adults mocking young kids even
teenagers just for the benefit of the
show not cool even Oprah was guilty of
it she should have left this one alone
at the time there were some rumors going
around about the twins Mary Kate and
Ashley struggling with their Weight and
Body Image remember they're teenagers
she straight up blurted out the new room
was recently surfaced has really upset
you right oh you know the one about
eating who asks that Ashley tried
playing it off you know people are going
to write what they want to write but
Oprah wasn't letting it go what size are
you by the way
five poor girls they were so caught off
guard this was all just a couple months
before Mary Kate actually checked
herself into rehab for an eating
disorder making this interview
especially cringe looking back and then
Lindsay Lohan yeah she knows the Olsen
twins pain is a fellow child star when
the 12 year old appeared on Jimmy Carter
he opened with this cringe question well
Lindsay with all this Fame and Fortune
how's your love life doing how the boys
doing a little awkward but but Lindsay
replied no I I don't need a boyfriend
yet good answer except he doubled down
on it if your father advised you to stay
away from all boys because they're bad
let me do that as a fatherly thing stay
away from it yikes we can see why
Lindsay would later say that she's a
little jealous of young stars who have
more control over their own narratives
but the thing is sometimes the problem
isn't the interviewers but the
interviewee Ryan Gosling said a few
things we imagine he regrets in an
interview he gave after landing his
first role as young Hercules at the age
of 18. the thing about Ryan is he got
beat up every now and then when he was a
kid so a win-like landing the role of
Hercules it had his mom calling every
kid that used to beat me up that might
not be a thing to brag about Ryan she's
like remember Ryan used to beat him up
huh well he circulates now he isn't
hearing us and when asked about any
girls who want his autograph let's take
him out anyone anyone wants to go out
they can come out with me I'm not picky
super cringe come on listen I don't know
why we got to play this game you know
let's just get married now as we've
clearly seen interviews can be tough for
young actors and Macaulay Culkin he was
not spared the literal child actor was
stuck with this brutal question did you
want to go into the business or did your
mom and dad think it would be a good
thing for you when asked about his
favorite subjects at school math science
and gym the interviewers even accused
him of lying you know what it says on
our cards gym and lunch you cleaned it
up for the show for the real thing right
what like why are they throwing him
under the bus like this
these actors somehow made it out alive
but the cringe is still very real which
one of these interviews were you most
surprised by make sure to let us know
down in the comments and let us know if
there are any cringe interviews that we
should check out next